a Chinese woman eating a whole bat at a
fancy restaurant has gone viral as China
and other countries in the world are
trying to contain the spread of the
Wuhan virus code name 2019 and cob in
America today they're lining up for
Firepower we're just concerned that
people might be getting a little crazy
now they can just say Corona
um
you know
this is
how are you doing how's everything over
there in Colorado
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah everything
is doing wonderful
uh everybody is anxious
uh you know there is a the level of
anxiety and and fear is is really
mounting uh uh of course uh you know the
uh the way that non-muslims address the
subject you know out of extra precaution
uh they wanted to uh
you know uh scare people so that they
can take the measures they are advising
but they don't know that they are
actually scaring them in a way
I don't know what is your secret what I
was thinking it's a it's a really uh uh
it's a great reality check for all of us
it's kind of surreal isn't it it's uh
you've heard this term surreal
yeah yeah I heard it it's it's it's a
great reality check to to Really uh uh
who we should depend on and how things
can take a drastic change I mean in this
case a lot of times for the better or in
this case what's seems for the worse but
it just kind of uh has us to put
ourselves in check on really who we
should be depending on
uh you know it is a test of faith to say
the least yeah
uh the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in an authentic Hadith
uh um
the Holy Spirit which is uh in reference
to jibra
revealed the following
by breathing into me
the following meanings the following
things
no soul shall die
until the soul lives the time
it was written for it to live
and until the soul collects the
provision which was destined to collect
Allah
so have be conscious of Allah and seek
your provision from lawful means
so that's the uh that's the provision of
faith during the time of
calamities and hardship I believe are
always any results
uh to his belief in Allah
Because he believes nothing happens in
the face of this Earth unless Allah
number one knew it
wrote it 50 000 years before he created
the heavens and the Earth
willed for it to happen
and he created it can you imagine that
so when you have that attitude and you
trust Allah his wisdom Allah his Divine
wisdom then you know you will certainly
deal with the situation totally
different than people who do not have
the provision of Faith the uh I mean by
the provision the immunity the um
The Treasure of believing in something
and and that's the key you know
stuff like this we know imagine
we this covid-19 is a relief for some
Muslims
a relief from sins
that the Hadith is authentic the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam says anything
which befalls a believer
uh depression
oh
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
went down as far as a sword
which would go into your body
accidentally
unless Allah expeed your sins yeah
subhanallah I relieve also in the same
I mean what is the worst case scenario
here
it actually can be a reward
and we have Companions of the Prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam brother Eddie
who died in similar uh benedemic like
this
which took place in the greater Syria
the year 1800 after Hijra
can you imagine died
by the way is one of the ten companions
one of the people who was giving black
Tiding of Jannah
he he died in in this Uhaul
can you imagine
died in this town died in this plague as
well
in a way
it is a reward and a person who dies in
such
of course dies as a Muslim
uh gains the rank of a martyr
Society
one day he asked his companions
who do you consider a martyr amongst you
they said o messenger of Allah whoever
dies in the cause of Allah is considered
to be a martyr then the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam said
then the martyrs in my ummah will be few
and then he started naming and one of
the things which he named
and whoever dies in a plague in a
benademic like this is considered to be
a martyr of course if he dies with a
Muslim
it's a relief it's a reward it's a
reminder for us Eddie yeah it's a
reminder for the living the the world
yeah go ahead finish I'm sorry the world
has gone crazy yeah I think this is what
really
resonates with a lot of people you know
in Islam you have all the answers uh to
the the million dollar questions you
know people's uh are confused there's
uncertainty but you go from a land of
uncertainty to certainty in Islam Islam
connecting you with your creator with
your purpose in life why you're here
where you're going everything is there
now we see that the reality check that I
was talking about and this is what I
want to want to get your feedback on is
that we know now this brings Solace to
the heart you know that at the end you
put trust in your Creator God Almighty
Allah and you know that there's
tremendous reward for all your suffering
you're not attached to this temporary
world you have it in your hand not in
your heart that's how we're supposed to
have it and now people are starting to
see everything just crumble in front of
them they're seeing everything you know
people's jobs are at stake their
livelihood you know tomorrow food can
Allah forbid can be cut off you you're
you're basically seeing everything it's
a domino effect I mean we're optimistic
as Muslims where we just see everything
that people thought as something that
this is what I live for this is what I
love it's like just Vanishing slowly and
it's brought people down to the level of
fighting for toilet paper
I just want one pack no not one pepper
all right amazing amazing yeah the the
scenes so you get to see where uh on one
Spectrum you see people who have just
lived for this Dunya for this world and
now they're about to lose it and the
Panic is kicking in now you see the
other side where you see now okay it
should be a mercy for people who come
back to their creator come back to to
the um to to Allah this this should be a
mercy so it can it good can come from it
we start to look but now I want to ask
you how can we as those uh who believe
in the one God just like Jesus Moses
Abraham the last Muhammad peace and
blessed be upon them those who are on
pure monotheism who want to live a good
righteous life who want to get to Jannah
how can we be more proactive meaning
that we've seen this now and many
Muslims have fallen into the Trap that
now how can we inshallah we get through
this but how can we also we can be more
proactive you know the prophet saws he
dug a train French right he didn't just
say okay I believe in Allah but you take
the necessary action we know the the
Hadith for the prophet saw some when the
man came to him and told him you know
should I just believe in Allah and leave
the camel or tie he said tie the camp
put your trust in Allah yeah for next
time now these things can happen where
we're being more we are being more
self-sustaining uh we are we are not at
the mercy where tomorrow if I think it's
making a point dear regarding us as
Believers uh how can we go back to Allah
is that your question or yeah yes at the
same time looking for in every situation
looking for the good in situations from
the smallest things to the big things I
was I was uh I was thinking also about
being more proactive now tomorrow that
if something like this was to happen
where we're less dependent and we're
more self self uh sufficient in ways of
let's say farming agricultural in ways
where tomorrow now let's say what
happens if the Practical things if the
the stores they run out of food you know
if uh are there are there other means
you know I often think of you know when
you think of a community like the Amish
for instance you know who are kind of
totally cut off from a lot of modern
technology but Islam doesn't call us to
go to that extreme but developing let's
say our communities where we have
agriculture we have farming we have uh
we have our own meat our own food we
have things like this these are ideas to
throw around because people would never
think that something would come to
fruition like this but it's happened so
the believer doesn't get stung by the
same hole twice so these are ideas that
we throw around and then hopefully
people can start to run with these
things and make great things happen so
tomorrow now uh hopefully some hearts
can awaken up and maybe put some
projects together that we don't find
ourselves in the same hole where we're
dependent and now the some of these
resources are cut off and you're so
dependent on Walgreens and so dependent
on whole on Aldi and whatnot and that's
it when they run out you're done
uh I'm gonna take this to a higher level
please go ahead
and and I I read something on social
media just this afternoon
just this afternoon Eddie and and you
can imagine uh you know that
uh argument or that
um
posting
it means all a lot
of course we don't we shouldn't be
making by against non-muslims that's how
the person started his posting he said
all Muslims please do not make Dua
again it's not Muslims until they find
out a cure
for covid-19 for us yeah
okay can you imagine that statement it
means the world man we say that so he
said don't make Dua until they find a
don't make Dua against them yeah
until they find a cure for us Muslims
that's horrible yeah this is a horrible
the whole well it's horrible but it
tells you the mindset of Muslims this is
kind of Twisted yeah it's it's totally
twisted
uh first of all we shouldn't be making
Dua against other people
we should make Dua for their guidance
this is number one number two
what happened to you as a Muslim trying
to find a cure for this
trying to find solutions for this
not to be stuck like everybody else like
you mentioned with with running out of
food and running out of of Basics
because you're just used to going to uh
you see the prophet saw Allah
has indicated
that we have to seek the means
and seeking the means is part of the
reliance
even in that situation like right now we
have that trending closing the message
not closing the message again this is a
means we cannot address the subject
using emotions and and healings and and
you see Islam
emphasizes uh the uh substantial uh
necessity on every Muslim or need on
every Muslim to seek the means in their
hands in their hands regardless of how
big or small it is and you you use a
very
they could have just sat there and done
nothing and say hey we rely on the law
but now they're taking the means so you
gave one and you gave one example now
okay using the best of Minds to go ahead
and find cures for these things uh
second one I was talking about
agricultural farming being productive we
know the prophet saw some said that if
the day of judgment was to come this is
this is that optimism is beautiful in
our Dean if it was to come upon you then
go ahead and if you have a sapling if
you have a seed go ahead and plant it
right so we're we're not pessimists
we're optimists but at the same time you
have to be pragmatic and you also have
to be proactive so another thing share
uh maybe you got some ideas you know
with all this growing hate in
islamophobia and whatnot obviously doing
dawah and educating people open houses
but at the same time I mean let me ask
you something uh are you practicing your
constitutional right to bear arms
across the United States tonight several
cities have shut down closing schools
restaurants and implementing curfews one
of the more Sinister sites queues of
customers lining up to Panic by weapons
fearing civil unrest and riots
forget toilet paper in America today
they're lining up for Firepower we're
just concerned that people might be
getting a little crazy Anthony Gordon
among dozens waiting for hours outside
this gun store in Los Angeles I've
always been on the fence about owning a
gun but we had a family discussion about
it and thought it was the right move at
this time preparing to protect
themselves in the event of civil unrest
this is unprecedented in the United
States Amelia Adams 9 News
uh what are you I'm just talking I'm
just asking I'm just like we're just
throwing ideas do you think that do you
think that every
where okay do you do you think do you
think that every American should now
let's say any Mom especially who's on
who can possibly be under threat should
should uh a be uh uh practicing
self-defense a martial art the community
should also be uh learning how to defend
themselves and their families should
they take should they take what should
they practice their con I'm just asking
we're just throwing ideas around should
they in all this hate and fear you have
250 uh plus uh uh functioning KKK
organizations these people who are Lynch
you tomorrow if they had a chance most
likely uh you have a lot of these
biggest these uh people out there who
you know will take these opportunities
take these opportunities
[Music]
[Music]
this is what uh Abel said to Cain uh-huh
is you're going to extend your hand to
kill me I'm not going to do the same
absolutely yes I'm I'm just gonna try to
defend myself in the exactly yes but I'm
not going to inflect that's my uh yeah
that's our that's our us that's how we
should be we are people of Peace we
spread peace but at the same time uh
what we're saying is where you had in
New Zealand the horrific terror attack
that unfolded in New Zealand overnight
not one but two mosques in Christ Church
were targeted the country's worst mass
shooting ever at least 49 people were
killed and dozens would enduring
Services they were in prayer victims who
did get out covered in blood were rushed
to the hospital the gunman who wrote of
white nationalism was armed with at
least two semi-automatic weapons and two
rifles you had someone who came up in
the Masjid and gunned down 50 people
then you had not too long ago more than
who who was attacked and a old man put
him in a choke hold and saved the day so
should we learn how to to do chokeholds
meaning to defend ourselves against
these lunatics these people who are out
there who want to bring harm while we're
trying to bring peace and should we be
more proactive in this in in in the
growing environment of hate and
terrorism that's being done towards uh
innocent human beings
absolutely and self-defense absolutely
that's the key self-defense it's
it's lawful this is number one
number two it is legal in Islam to do
that is it I'm sorry it's lawful in
Islam and it is legal according to the
law of the land you can do it a hundred
percent you know what it was you know I
was selling out more than than food uh
weapons yeah I read that and I was
shocked yeah I was shocked also yeah
yeah I mean why people are buying guns
so let me ask you this let's paint a
scenario let's paint a scenario you're
you're a law-abiding citizen you're in
your home you you do all the good stuff
pay your taxes you you want good for
Humanity you're a deliverer of Peace but
now you know there's there is uh these
situations happen things starts breaking
down and now you're at your home you
have your your your your family in your
home how are you prepared if these
criminals come to your home and try to
inflict harm upon yourself and your
family see these these situations like
this that are happening should have us
start to think to think how do we defend
ourselves when people start coming to
our homes and they want to bring harm to
to you and your family how do you defend
yourself you have no idea
you have 9-1-1 you have to call 9-1-1
obviously you have to call 9-1-1 right
but let's say you know it's just like
with everything's happening they're all
spread out they're all over the place
people might be getting a little crazy
I've always been on the fence about
owning a gun but we had a family
discussion about it and thought it was
the right move at this time preparing to
protect themselves in the event of civil
unrest everyone one is entitled to
defend himself that's why these people
want to buy the guns they want to buy
the guns because people might be getting
a little crazy yeah but we're so scared
of guns I don't like weapons but it has
you thinking now Sheikh it has you
thinking like you know uh the worst case
scenarios we rely on the creator of the
heavens and earth but we also have to be
pragmatic and what happens these are
you're the shake you got to start
talking to us so I I really at this
stage uh Eddie
um a lot of people are misinformed about
Islam yeah
and my brother
I don't care less
what is the agenda of every individual
living in the west is
but I tell you
our agenda is to show people the beauty
of that religion to show people Islam
yeah to call people to the monotheism to
to to to do the same like Jesus to do
the same like Moses to worship Allah the
Creator not the created yes and we have
to conduct ourselves
the way our messenger and his companions
conducted themselves
a lot of them were killed a lot of them
were hard
in the course
because their focus was the course and
he just cited the trench yeah imagine
all the evil power
Powers plural in the face of this Earth
got together
with a mutual agenda to wipe Islam from
the face of this Earth
but Allah protected his religion
but also some people died
in the course yeah and that's what
matters
so you know we can defend ourselves but
I'm really here to show people the
beauty of this religion
and you know
and somehow
uh
the status of Assam the level of Assad
when you give Dao
is
uh highly recommended
uh we have as imams and and callers to
Islam and and the way that we call to
Islam we have a lot of people who don't
like us yeah even in the Muslim
Community themselves they don't like you
they don't like how you uh you're doing
it and they inflict harm on you but you
still have to just move on you know so I
really shouldn't be sort of infesting
myself too much into that Seer yes of no
we really have to look into the uh area
here of Allah is the best of protectors
yes seek the means do your best but what
if it happens that you die in the course
yeah
this is another way to earn the rank of
a martyr that you die defending your
family and your wills and your home
you're a master yeah and and a Martha
someone who was right away to Jannah do
you think you know I know anywhere
you're coming from and I I know I know
that you're trying to address a lot of
Minds out there not just the mind of an
Imam or I know that you're trying to
accommodate
a lot of people who are thinking in that
line I know 100 that you don't think in
that line but I know that that that's
what you're trying to do and and you
know
just
um find your Fortress and and they
believe in Allah and seek whatever means
you have in your hand and rely on Allah
and Allah will protect you and your
family inshallah how would you uh give
the explanation of this Hadith is in in
sahil bukhari where the Prophet saw some
had said uh soon the best property of a
Muslim one who submits to the will of
God will be a flock of sheep he takes to
the top of the mountain or The Valleys
of the rainfall fleeing with his Dean
from tribulations some people start to
reference this now at these times is
this a good parallel
[Music]
just for me to reflect upon its meanings
before I explain what it entails the
provision or the earning of a Muslim is
to be a Shepherd not in in in a place
where are there where there are people
rather a place where uh you know there
is nobody basic basically the top of a
mountain or a place basically or running
away from the table because of the
amount of trials and tribulations uh in
the area of your religion the subject
Eddie is in in the area of what is
recommended to mix with the people
or to isolate yourself from the people
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
answered this question
to mix with them
provided that you're protecting your
religion
you're not paying off your religion as a
prize to be with the people
and to be patient on their heart
to you
is a lot better
to isolating yourself from them
the prophet answered this so the
criteria here is am I protecting my
religion while I'm mixing with the
people
even though they are harming me
then it's a lot better than isolating
yourselves and going somewhere in a cave
or somewhere else then always in Islam
Eddie Islam looks at the uh
the goodness which get gets passed on to
others is more rewarded in Islam than
the goodness which is exclusive to you
provided that your
keen on sincerity your sincerity in your
heart but you're giving it openly with
the intention of encouraging others to
give is much better
but if you conceal it and you give it in
secret and give it to the poor
it's good for you only but the other one
is much better why because you will
encourage other Muslims to give so if
you mix with the people for sure you
will benefit them you will teach them
you will educate them
but according to Hadith at this time
uh I'm telling you uh
I find my best place is inside my office
where I I sit with my books and
you know I that's
but I still have to go out and and earn
a living and and and and and and that's
you know part of it and and that's part
of the test
um and and fitness
that we Face outside uh it's it's there
and and you can't stop it and you can't
control it
uh so the answer is quoting this Hadith
uh as uh an excuse to withdraw from the
community and the society and do nothing
uh that's not a good thing you should be
out there hopefully engaged in helping
the ummah teaching the people the
religion uh trying to better the
people's understanding
yes you will face what you have to face
and that's the uh it's called the
inheritance of prophethood
or not prophets our messenger is the
last
but if we are to do his work in the
manner he did it he had enemies
it was called names
his family was attacked in their honor
he was called the possessed lying and
that's the chair that you get
and that's that that's it now as long as
this does not affect your sincerity uh
your uh tawheed your religion it doesn't
take you away from the truth it doesn't
get you to compromise your reward is
tremendous in the sight of Allah what do
you think it's very interesting uh
another thing we can see here is uh from
this uh what is being called as the
Coronavirus
and and we know that this is uh what
they the experts say that this is
another strand of it this has been
around this Corona but then you have it
mutate and you have other strands of it
that come out but it's amazing that you
have to to see this coronavirus you have
to magnify it by a hundred thousand you
can't see with the naked eye it's
amazing but now when you ask people like
uh again uh people who haven't seen this
coronavirus they're relying uh and and
we're not you know you know I'm laughing
I know I'm laughing because I did a
video last night and I know what you're
gonna say yeah I know you know we have
the atheist who refuse to believe in our
love exactly Allah exactly you know
that's the point that's what I'm trying
to make and I want to go deeper they're
relying we are all relying on testimony
am I right we're relying on testimony
which a lot of the testimony from the
people we're getting I don't think
Behati would accept most of their uh uh
transmission no no right I think that a
lot of currency a lot of rumors about
this uh Buffet yeah so so now but we're
we're practicing what the dean tells us
to practice to be uh uh safe and to
protect ourselves so we can
um uh uh protect the elderly and and
people from potentially getting hurt and
dying and but we we are just pretty much
following the testimony believing in the
testimony Without Really seeing the
things ourselves but now the correlation
is that we have people who have come
through history who have a greater track
record a pristine character never to
have lied and this is one of the signs
that if people reflect
they have a greater right to be believed
people who warn people about the day of
judgment people who called people to
worship one and only one God the Creator
not the creation but now when you think
you know for the atheists that you
specifically mentioned who didn't see
this virus didn't see this uh or any of
this he's relying on this testimony of
people but now if you think and you
correlate the two isn't that ironic just
when you it's
that shows you that Twisted minds of
people sometimes
and something amazing and I hope that
people uh you know especially students
of knowledge are not going to go hard on
me because I'm doing this
uh you know why we cannot see this virus
I'm sure you know why because it's very
what
it's not but the human eye can't see it
you can see it with the naked eye
because so small yeah actually I read
that you have to have a magnifying glass
400 times that's what I I heard I heard
a hundred a thousand times more whatever
it is yeah but but you know why we
cannot see Allah subhanallah
because of his greatness yes
because of his magnificence Muslim
ation
one day the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam stood up and he delivered five
meaningful words
I'm gonna jump to the fifth one
in Allah
between us and Allah is made out of
light
if this Veil is lifted what will happen
everything will burn
everything will because you cannot
handle the greatness of Allah you cannot
comprehend you cannot these little eyes
cannot look into the greatness of Allah
imagine the sun is one of the creative
things by Allah just you know when
you're driving in the highway and you
see the sun just shining into your eyes
what do you need to do with it you bring
that thing down right and the car down
because he can't look and this is a
created things so that shows you uh
brother Eddie
the the beauty of Iman the beauty of
faith and and believing in Allah
Allah he brothers and sisters in Islam
the best Bounty that a Muslim have
especially at these times is to believe
in Allah
because I know even if I die in this
Benedict
has a better plan for me you know what
even if I get
if I get it Allah has a good plan for me
because listen Allah always turns if you
believe in him always turn something bad
to be good bad according to you to be
good at the end so that that's the
beauty of Islam imagine the people who
do not believe in Allah what is the what
is their position now they are scared
they are afraid that they hear every
single rumor out there and they are that
they are currently over a virus which
they cannot see subhanallah
alhamdulillah and and like you were
saying you look for the good in all
situations and it's a part of our Deen
to be optimistic Allah Allah the creator
of the heavens and earth loves uh for us
to be optimistic is that correct
optimism
uh always is this uh is this authentic
Hadith that uh I'm paraphrasing that
Allah loves the optimistic slave the one
who is optimistic
well the prophet sallam commanded us to
be optimistic yes and himself especially
any at these times you know I go back to
that dreams
yeah I go back to the trench
while the Muslims were digging the
French Eddie
this incident happened
a group of diggers of believers who were
digging that fence they came across a
huge rock cover beneath the sand
they could not break it
so they immediately reported the matter
to the prophet saws
the acts and he came and he started
hammering this rock and you know when
metal and rock Collide
we got sparks flying imagine in this
situation the prophet is telling his
companions what Allahu Akbar
he's saying God is the greatest and this
is a prophecy now
Islam which you were standing for our
cause here will will get to the Roman
Empire submission to the will of the
Creator not the creation
not not just to Virgin it will enter the
balances of Virgin Allah
imagine imagine in that situation to the
extent that actually there were some
Hypocrites amongst the Muslims and we
know the campaign of hypocrisy started
in Medina they said
Allah documented this in the Quran
[Music]
the Hypocrites would say look at these
guys they cannot even fight an army and
they are taking a trench in order for
them not to advance and they are saying
that they're going to go to the Roman
Empire you see that's the attitude of
the Prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
especially at these times and and that's
what I believe you must give good news
to the people listen guys Allah is in
control Allah will take care listen
uh I I I love this Hadith out of this
world
one of the ansar was dying Eddie
her son is
out of town
heard that his father is going through
the agonies of death
so he immediately got on his horse and
he ran back to Medina
one thing to catch at least a final
moment with his father ovanda was a
learned companion by the way he narrated
a lot of Hadith as well
so when he entered into the room
he said
my father I came running to hear a final
word from him
give me the best wasilia that you can
give
you know what he said to him first of
all he was laying down because he was
dying he said to the people Help me sit
down and he looked at his son and he
said yeah my son
the sweetness of faith the knowledge of
Iman
until you believe
[Music]
that whatever inflected you was not to
miss you and whatever missed you was not
to inflect you imagine this attitude
imagine when you walk out yes
yes
that's the attitude of a Believer and
you cannot pay for this you cannot pay
for this because this has to come from
within because of your because of your
certainty because of your faith in Allah
because of your belief in the Hereafter
because of your belief in uh
but again
we we go back to Roma
you know when Omar ended up in the midst
of That League in Syria and and
so he was around Jerusalem area and the
area was not inflected yet because the
original uh blade or benademic or tahoon
happened in a city called the mwas
so Omar
wanted to go and visit the troops there
so the people said to him listen there
is a plague there at this time by the
way they did not have
any information should they go or should
they not
so Omar in the morning you know woke up
and he said you know what I made up my
mind I'm gonna go back to Medina
so one of the people debated him and he
said what to him look at this Eddie look
what he said
oh commander of the faithful
are you fleeing from the Qatar of Allah
isn't Allah wrote everything right are
you running away from the color of Allah
why don't you go to that place where
there is the plague you know what Omar
said to him I'm seeking the means I'm
running away from the Qatar of Allah and
I'm going away to also
so we seek in the means also is within
the color of Allah Subhan Allah one of
the companions his name is and that
portion of the story in Muslim he came
in the morning and he said yeah I
actually heard the prophet salallahu
saying if you hear of a plague in a town
don't enter it and if you're there don't
come out uh so he kind of confirmed what
Omar concluded on his own uh
alhamdulillah
you know that shows you all
system which is they're not Muslims the
best
non-muslim secular system in the morning
is adopting the quarantine which the
prophet salallahu alaihi sallam and
Islam introduced
1400 or 50 58 1451 years ago can you
imagine this amazing huh America
51 years ago
Imagine This
and one more thing Eddie one more thing
do you know why the whole thing of
coronavirus was caused
I mean in a city called wehan right or
wahan in China
because what what were they eating
huh what were they eating
things which Allah told us not to eat
isn't that beautiful
things which Allah told us not to
you know a lot of people that you know
this verse that when when uh when I came
to the prophet and he said there is a
verse in your book
there is a verse in your book if it was
revealed Upon Us Jews we would have
taken that even which this verse was
revealed the day of aid so um
which verse today I completed the
religion for you you know you know this
verse this is not the verse by the way
this is like the ending of the verse you
know how this verse begins how does it
begin huh
[Music]
it is
not slaughtered according to imagine and
then Allah says I completed the religion
for you I told you what to eat and what
not to eat and that's another beauty of
Islam you know that you're conducting
your your life in a way that the Creator
the maker the one who made you uh once
you to to do it and and that's the
beauty that Islam is a beauty at all
times especially at these times
Believers now I'm telling you are the
most uh
um
the strongest but that strength comes
from Allah not not because of them that
comes from Allah in facing this because
of their Iman because of their faith
there's a few few more uh questions
going back to what you were saying about
the what they were eating in Wuhan What
specifically were were
they known for eating in this area
eating a whole bat at a fancy restaurant
has gone viral as China and other
countries in the world are trying to
contain the spread of the Wuhan virus
code name 2019 and cob
they were eating
moving things we cannot eat that yeah
you see they were eating
um uh scorpions yeah they were eating
dogs they were eating cats
we don't eat that this is all prohibited
in Islam to uh to eat any of these
animals
you know when you go and buy a car yes a
manual they give you a manual right yeah
who made your body
who made your buddy the Creator Allah
then Allah knows what is good for this
body right yeah he giving you the manual
too right the manual is there for you
eat this do not eat that and that is why
Muslims should be man man subhanallah
uh Salman Pharisee this is the one who
recommended by the way that that Prince
that idea of the prince siddhaq our
night is the night of the prince he's
the one who recommended the trends to
the prophet he met a virgin like him
Muslim
so he said to him man
your religion teaches you everything
even how to go to the bathroom
you know you know any any secular Muslim
now any I don't know if there is such a
thing called secular Muslim but any
Progressive Muslim and I don't know what
does it mean either I mean I mean I have
a Mac
and if you go back you can go back you
know you know that I have iPhone I have
11 alhamdulillah is that what
Progressive means I don't know what does
it mean Progressive these days but in a
progressive Muslim now say oh no I don't
do that you know this is only for the
guys who are really into the religion
will run away from me no you know you
know what he said to him Salman yes
I'm around the prophet salallahu
commanded us to enter the bathroom with
our left feet and not to use our right
hand cleaning ourselves and he he told
us to do at least three times in order
to clean ourselves and not imagine he's
describing to him how to do number two
it's proud proud of his of his religion
of Islam right now Muslims Unfortunately
they shy away from the best religion in
the face of this Earth which offers them
how to deal with this Dynamic Eddie
unfortunately yeah that's that's an
interesting you mentioned that because
just from that small thing that we would
think is small it would it would have
prevented so many people almost killing
themselves for toilet paper
yeah yeah because of the 100 because of
uh if they knew how to properly uh
cleanse themselves people knew how to
close themselves in the bathroom
toilet paper so you know what I told
myself alhamdulillah we can go back to
the uh you know alhamdulillah when I was
raised up I never had toilet papers
yeah so from the small things to the big
things the small uh thing is you know
we're also another another great uh
thing that someone can pull from this is
that someone who's been struggling
because sometimes you know Islam allows
people to have their space respecting
women to such a high level and women
who've been struggling and Men also uh
worrying about offending someone uh of
the opposite gender now they can just
say Corona
[Music]
there are certain things if you would
talk about them you are a fanatic you
know imagine the Hadith is authentic man
Allah nobody can debate its authenticity
it's better for you to be stabbed with a
needle than to shake a hand of opposite
gender not lawful for you alhamdulillah
doesn't have to do it Corona Corona
yeah another another thing that I did I
did this morning you know that you know
we have that that uh that also uh act
that after we say
I think it came from Egypt because I was
brought up with this and and the person
would shake your hand and will say Haram
you know so that's again another thing
that disappeared from the message which
is a beautiful because it's really nice
supposed to engage in our stuff for
Allah for Allah Allah
you're not supposed to to engage in
handshaking and that's beautiful but you
can do this after they have cut outside
but they immediate part of the Salah
that you have to now you don't have to
do it anymore so it's all good I want to
end with this uh one story and we can
end with this inshallah is where once uh
this is a intimidi uh and you can go
ahead and take it from here once I
finish uh putting these two together
that once uh the prophet saws he went to
see a young man who was on his deathbed
and he asked him how do you feel the
young man said I have much hope from
Allah but I also have fear my sins the
prophet saws said the believer who has
these two ideas simultaneously at such
time Allah fulfills his hopes and grants
him security from his fear so now uh can
you go ahead and explain this because a
lot of people they'll have this uh one
over the other but this is a perfect
balance
foreign
[Music]
foreign my
banking
is on Allah My Hope on Allah My Hope Is
On Allah no other
My Hope Is Not on my good deeds
is not in my good deeds
you're getting that yes
and I'm not afraid of Allah but I'm
afraid of the consequences of my sins
you see
that short statement
reflects that this person
possesses the right belief system
that is why the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam commended by saying no believer
in that particular because you see we
always live between fear and hope Eddie
and while you're alive
and Healthy and Wealthy and will us
your wing of fear should be up
then or more than the wings of Hope but
while you're dying your wing of Hope
must be up and and this is exactly what
this young boy or young man stated that
listen my hope is in Allah is in his
Mercy why because the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam
three days and the one who narrated this
Hadith is
he said I heard the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam three days before his
death saying
none of you should die unless or until
he has High Hopes regarding Allah so
good expectation from Allah so he's
doing this and Allah
see that I'm the way my slave think of
me
so he is doing that and he's afraid of
the sins that he's having and that
should be our attitude have your hope in
Allah that Allah can save you that Allah
can save your family that Allah can save
your ummah but what about this you know
make a promise
you know and there is nothing wrong with
that by the way
foreign
you know after his father was killed in
Burgers Crema because became so Furious
so angry that he attacked the prophet
salallahu right and left
the eighth year after Hijra when the
prophet came conquering he named the
ekrima to be taken care of Crema ran
away
because he knew that he will be
held accountable not like any not like
the others the others are forgiving like
Yusuf said to his brothers
I'm gonna get him
on a ship
and a Crema
is on on the ceiling with a group of of
non-muslims
and a thunderstorm erupted
the storm is the ship is about to sink
everybody is about to drown
imagine the captain of the ship called
upon everybody on board is it guys you
know these Stones these creative beings
that you you're worshiping cannot help
you heal the only one who can help you
is Allah
imagine what akrima did o Allah if you
save me tonight if you saved me today I
will go back to the messenger of Allah
and I will become a Muslim and I will
work for Islam I will make it up this is
what we want from every Muslim who is
hearing you tonight Eddie and hearing me
and hearing make a promise
to Allah that if Allah would save you
from that covid-19 what will you do
there's nothing wrong with that akrima
did it but be truthful don't be plastic
about it don't be plastic don't be think
about it be fruitful really mean it you
know what Crema went back and the
prophet forgive him and he accepted
Islam you know he was dying in a battle
called bringing Islam to the Roman
Empire the border of Turkey
he was dying at the end of this battle
you know and he was looking at the
people around him and he was telling
them
imagine this if rasulullah would see me
dying like this he think he would be
happy that I have made up for the time I
imagine
we call upon every believer
make a promise
that if Allah saves you
save the ummah save your family that you
will change you will be a better Muslim
you will serve this Deen you will make a
better commitment to Allah and and
that's you know we all should do that
and and this is in a way you repenting
because listen what we have now because
of a sin whether it is my sin I'm not
saying I'm innocent whether it is your
sin his sin their sin Collective sin
there is a sin the prophet said that any
Affliction like this any Collective
disaster like this doesn't come down
unless there is a sin and the only way
for it to be listed and removed
and this is one way to make tawa that
you say Allah I haven't been praying
five times I'm going to pray five times
oh Allah I haven't been giving thou I'm
going to give down oh Allah I haven't
been helping the ummah and then I'm
going to give them I'm going to help the
needy I'm gonna help the poor I'm going
to be nice to my neighbors I'm going to
tell the truth I'm gonna stop harming
people just make a promise any promise
anything and may Allah accept from all
of us I mean beautiful we and on that
and that was the the story to really
have people reflecting uh hope in your
creator being optimistic but at the same
time using this as a reality check to
check ourselves like you said if you're
not praying uh connecting with your
creator minimum five times a day making
Toba staying away from the things that
are harmful for you in society
pornography gambling selling alcohol
indulging in drugs and nightclubs and
all the devices that are out there that
are destroying you and your family to
society living by the blueprint sent for
all of mankind this Dean's submission to
the Creator not the creation Islam and
that's how we can strike a beautiful
balance and inshallah that's how we can
be successful
now in this life and definitely
attaining Jannah with Allah's Mercy in
the next thank you Sheikh for uh sharing
your time with us and and going over
this
keep up the faith man be firm listen if
I don't see you in this world we're
gonna see in Jannah okay inshallah
listen that's that's the beauty if I
don't see you guys in this world we're
gonna see you on gender attitude of a
Believer man our next meeting can be
Jannah inshallah
[Music]